medication absorption is the movement of
a drug from its side of administration
into the blood
oral drugs enter the stomach where they
either dissolve
and pass through the cell membranes of
epithelial cells lining the stomach
or travel undissolved through the
stomach to the small intestine which is
the most common side of absorption
here drugs dissolve
and pass through the intestinal wall
oral drugs then travel through the
portal venous system to the liver where
they undergo the first pass effect
during this process the liver
metabolizes some of the drug either
inactivating it
or excreting it into bile for
elimination from the body
the remaining amount of active drug
leaves the liver and reaches General
circulation and Target organs
if a drug is administered via
intravenous injection it passes directly
into the bloodstream thus bypassing
absorption in the GI tract
if administered through intramuscular or
subcutaneous injection the drug enters
either muscle or subcutaneous tissue
where it passes through gaps between
cells into capillary walls and then into
General circulation or Target organs
also bypassing absorption in the GI
tract
bioavailability is the net amount of a
dose of a drug that is actually absorbed
into the bloodstream
the bioavailability of oral drugs is
less than 100 percent because of the
first pass effect of the liver
in contrast the bioavailability of IV
drugs is 100 percent because they are
not exposed to the first pass effect of
the liver
different drug formulations alter
bioavailability because they are not
absorbed at the same rate or to the same
extent
for example tablets dissolve at varying
rates
in terracotted drugs dissolve in the
small intestine not the stomach because
gastric emptying time differs between
individuals absorption times also vary
sustain release formulas contain tiny
spheres that dissolve at different rates
resulting in a steady drug release
throughout the day but also resulting in
variable absorption
some factors affecting drug absorption
are the rate of dissolution drugs that
dissolve faster are absorbed faster
surface area since the lining of the
small intestine has more surface area
than the lining of the stomach most
drugs are absorbed faster in the small
intestine
blood flow the greater the concentration
gradient between the drug-filled stomach
and the rapidly flowing drug-free blood
the faster the absorption
lipid solubility highly lipid soluble
drugs pass through the phospholipids in
the cell membrane more easily than drugs
of low lipid solubility
and pH partitioning absorption is faster
when the difference between the pH at
the site of administration and the pH of
the plasma attracts more drug molecules
to ionize in the plasma